hey guys and welcome to episode 96 of
the let's play this episode is just have
a tiny bit of making this whole area
with the building a tiny bit more fancy
it's nothing big I would say overall but
just trying to get the nice details
rights and of course the planter action
and all that stuff which is a really
important I really wanted to get some
simple foliage up on this little square
over here to get some different colors
in here because one thing that you'll
probably kind of notice when you look at
it is that Holland just has bricks a
[ __ ] everywhere there are red bricks
all over the place and yeah I wanted to
get some different colors in there but I
obviously couldn't really do that with
the building's themselves or I would
really break the theme so I wanted to
get some simple foliage in there just a
couple of simple planters and of course
flowers flowers are very important
especially for this sort of theme and if
you're wondering why I'm talking not
talking about the flag that is nothing
big really that's just a tiny bit of
Dutch pride have to put a flag in there
honestly now that's that is sort of the
idea for the park I don't know if I can
actually pull that off since there
aren't flags for all of the countries
that I'm trying to do but the ideas may
need to have at least one flag pour at
every spot of the country at every
little country area that being said I
still need a flag for Italy for that one
little town over there in the log flume
area but yeah I'm worried about what
sort of problems I'll run into as soon
as I catch her like the Asian parts of
this entire thing but that's something
for a later stage I mean honestly at
this point I haven't really talked about
it too much but I'm really worried about
the lifetime about this bike anyway it's
not that I'll give up on it but so far
I've been trying to do it in one plug
file and to be very honest that is
something that might not happen in the
end because rollercoaster country likes
to crush especially on larger parks and
people are already surprised that I'm
even planning to do it on one Park file
I'm just trying to get as far as I can
but I have to say I've already had some
crushes because roller coaster can three
just couldn't handle it ráma rám related
things and such it's just basically
because roller coaster 3 is so extremely
poorly optimized I see many
conversations about
like what sort of spikes you need to get
for all the Kousaka three if there's any
problems with your computer if you have
lag and such
yeah there's no real way to make
rollercoaster cone three actually work
for one it's very poorly optimized it
doesn't use all of the RAM on your
computer uses a max of two megabytes
that is something that you can fix by
taking a program called large address of
where by the way I suppose I can just
kind of advertise that at the moment if
you ever have problems with any sort of
Rococo second three part just random
crushes or that your computer can take
it or just lag in general get a program
called large address where it makes it
so you can give rollercoaster can three
more megabytes of RAM to use so if you
have for example a tram on your computer
a 8 MB RAM on your computer then you can
like make it use all of your RAM rather
than just a tiny bit of RAM that it's
actually using as it when it comes like
with it I'm not even sure exactly how
much it was but basically get the
program and its really awesome that's
just something I wanted to get out there
because I still see many people that
don't have the program and it can be
really handy when it comes to
rollercoaster III and it's also one of
the key points in how I'm trying to
hopefully actually make this park work
without crashes or anything because I've
basically just got a a life support for
rollercoaster tycoon 3 crashes focus on
my computer at the moment there is large
addresses where I use the pill I use the
park clean up whenever I can just to get
the megabytes down of the park size
because it's already way above 10
megabytes per node
cut it down a tiny bit which by the way
is your limits for any rollercoaster can
three park as soon as it hits like 10 or
higher for some reason you just start
getting crashes and lag and
rollercoaster q3 doesn't appreciate it
so those are things those are all of the
things that I need to avoid in any case
but yeah I haven't even talked about the
park for autonomy I'm sorry about that I
really just wanted to say that since
I've never really said it and I know
that this is not the video to do such a
thing I might at some point actually
make a separate video for it but then
again it's nothing really that big just
a tiny tip which is something that I
figured I I really need to put in the
last place since otherwise it's gonna be
to empty but that's enough Mayda talk
for now I really yeah this is just a
tiny bit of the buildings in the sides
which mind you that one corner building
I still don't have the cables for it
though as I'm speaking I am planning to
in a bit actually make those but I still
need to make those and that's also one
reason why this entire area is not
completely finished yet and all that and
I'm not really planning to add anything
to that little square there will be no
attractions or anything special maybe a
couple of stalls the will still be
lights and things like that because
those things are really really important
like the details that surround your
buildings is so often overlooked but the
look the way that a building is going to
look or a facade really it doesn't just
come down to what the building itself
looks but your planters the lights
everything around it makes such a
difference and especially if you get a
tiny bit of contrast in it so I have
like all of these red brick buildings at
the moment so just getting that tiny bit
of green in it with the foliage is just
almost a necessity really and this was
the bridge work by the way which I
suppose I could say I'm not too sure
about it actually liked it though but
it's it was a bit of an experiment I was
basically just skimming through sets and
seeing whatever I could use and then in
Pat's AFC said I think it's called
really random set I'm not even
completely sure what it is exactly all
about but it's it's really really set
and it has like also two misc stuff in
it and it also had these little ironwork
things and no idea what they're actually
supposed to look it's supposed to be or
supposed to look like like if you place
two next to each other like that I kind
of looks like a mustache but that's
completely off-topic I decided I would
actually try those on the lamps because
I've never really seen that before and
that was actually surprisingly good
there is a bit low though like you can
see that the lamp is pretty high and you
have the hanging baskets really
underneath that but you can't raise the
little ironworks and I think it looks
alright it definitely has a funny look
to it and I think this bridge is a whole
I know that the touch area is in the in
and of itself a bit of a transition area
within the park but this bridge also
hard to fit in both areas so that was
sort of
the well the little challenge when it
comes to building the bridge so I wanted
to use the lighter brick materials to
make it look sort of like a bridge that
you would find in the Mediterranean area
but getting those ironworks and those
lanterns like that and of course the
hanging baskets all that does also have
a bit of a Dutch touch so that was funny
so I suppose that it works for both
areas I don't think I'll really work on
that bridge anymore that's just an it's
just good to go I suppose at this point
and there is a little bit of path
artwork over there really simple though
I mustn't overuse those things because
I'm starting to get addicted to that
stuff even though it's really simple
just it can add such a nice touch to any
sort of centerpiece but what I do have
to say about path works like that is
don't do it too much and don't overdo it
because that's something that I'm trying
to not do at the moment like you only
have special art paths work like that
yeah it's sort of art work in a sense
too but you only have special paths work
like that
really and around fountains centerpieces
of a square things like that they are
not a completely unrealistic thing but
if you overdo or over place them it does
tend to start to get a tiny bit too
artistic and a tiny bit less realistic
now I'm wondering
oh this isn't that episode yet never
mind something big is actually gonna
happen in the future what actually let's
just talk about it anyway [ __ ] piece
of the stage is an awesome fellow he you
might know him
roller-coaster can 3 he also makes let's
play videos and stuff yeah I'm just
gonna plug people in my video but that's
not what I'm here to talk about it it
was actually kind of a funny little
series of events what I was going to
start working on a Dutch bridge you guys
may know if you live in Holland you know
about this you have those white
suspension draw bridges everywhere in
the Netherlands if you if you look up
pictures of Amsterdam you probably see
them - it's like suspension bridges but
they're really small they're often white
and they just have like two arms that
raise a very small pathway that crosses
a canal thatís basically how they work
because they they're so small because
they're for the canals and Holland is
[ __ ] full of canals of course and I
really wanted to get that in in the
middle of this just to get that Dutch
look but also get a passing sort of
suspension bridge for that little canal
that I have over here and I was just
about to make that and the minutes that
I was about to make that piece of steel
actually sent me a message that hey
whisker that he was actually working on
a Dutch bridge and he sent me a beta of
this set and it was absolutely amazing
it was just perfect and at that point I
just had to give up doing whatever I was
trying to start with that bridge and
that thing just fit in there like a
beautiful thing but that's something for
the next episode I'm very sorry I didn't
want to make any sort of cliffhanger
that's not my sort of thing but oh well
it's uh yeah you're gonna have to wait
until the next episode maybe even the
episode up to that coming real to the
next episode so yeah that's that I also
need to stop referencing songs in my
videos or I might do it more often
[ __ ] I've no idea in any case this was a
tiny bit of planning since I did get
some comments about the areas though I
think I have also noted that the current
planning that I had with the
terraforming was a tiny bit smaller than
what they're actually gonna be like it
was just a tiny bit of planning like
okay this is why I want that area and
this is where I won that area etc so I
would keep the I would keep those spaces
clean and kind of come up with a layout
because I have yet like I've yet to even
have any sort of idea what I'm going to
do layout wise if a paths attractions
and all that stuff in the next areas
what I do know though is the next area
that I'm probably going to work on it's
going to be English area the only thing
I really probably have to make for that
is the typical English chimneys honestly
see those things everywhere and with
that I it should be good to go I would
say and yeah that's basically gonna
probably I'm not sure about this but I'm
leaning towards a B and I'm stand up
which may seem like a real choice but I
feel like it would work in an English
area for some reason and it's a very
done thing and I want to get something
unique done so first roller coaster is
gonna happen in that area it's gonna
happen soon though maybe not before
episode 100 because you know the speed
at which I do these things but in any
case I see that I'm all out of time so
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you guys next time
I'll see you guys in the next episode